it's time for
night
presented by no one
of course uh by this time on monday
night we will have a new national
champion
in college football that's true uh i
hope it's a new national champion
in college football and i hope they're
wearing this
that's for sure georgia and alabama
going at it on monday
in indianapolis
for all of the college football is that
a real barbecue this that is it yeah
that's a great idea
hold on one second don't say it not do
not get ahead of yourself i'm sorry
about quotes because i speak
for all
look georgia given three right now i
mean alabama won the sec championship
game over georgia and i was there to
watch it and it was it was painful but
georgia favored by three over alabama in
the title game uh and i speak for all
university of georgia fans when i say
let's hope
let's just hope and pray
that charles barkley does not pick the
university of georgia to win the
national championship and before we hear
his pick
let's hear from a couple other georgia
products
and their thoughts
okay
hey chuck it's maria and i just had one
request please please please
do not bet on georgia to win the
national championship we do not need
that kind of bad luck we do not need it
okay
and also what bowl game is auburn
playing in please chuck whatever you do
do not bet with us in the national
championship man every time you bet with
us we lose and this one got to come back
to athens with us for sure
[Music]
maria taylor you know you're one of my
favorite people in the world you and my
girl catherine taples y'all do a
favorite job shout out to both of you
ladies anthony
you've been playing pretty good you've
been playing pretty good yeah
but
it's that time
to drive your bulldogs are gonna win the
national championship
[Applause]
[Applause]
university
hey
truckster yeah hey here we go
harry is unhappy right here
hey let me tell you man you already know
that picture it's too late to change you
look like half dog too nope i'm telling
you how would you like to change your
pick yeah
i hope it is their
it you time say it
hey you do you look like it's their time
man you look like the guy y'all guy in
the barber shop you look like harry
y'all look it's their time y'all harry
i'm sorry man
there's nothing i can do there's no
control in the all right yeah can we see
can i see that in slow motion
go
dogs sick them four four four four
oh
[Laughter]
oh that stuff is aggressive bulldogs
falling out of the ceiling
i'm taking this home